WOW, WE ARE CONNECTED TO THIS
MOVEMENT.
I FELT LIKE "SELMA" THE FILM IS
AN EXTENSION OF WHAT THEY
CREATED DURING THAT TIME PERIOD
BECAUSE NOW THAT FILM
IS EDUCATING LIKE YOUNGER
PEOPLE ON WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T KNOW. AND
IT'S ALSO RAISING THE
CONVERSATION OF LIKE WHAT,
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
AND OBVIOUSLY, ALL THESE
SITUATIONS HAPPENING IN AMERICA
ARE RAISING THE CONVERSATION.
>> Jon: YOU MEAN THAT
RACISM IS OVER.
YEAH, IT'S GOOD THAT IT'S OVER.
YEAH.
>> YEAH, YEAH. IS THAT WHAT
IT IS?
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE CALLING IT,
HUH?
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, IT JUST, IT
JUST, WHAT IT IS, WE JUST
HAPPENED TO CATCH THE LAST,
THE LAST ONE OF IT.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: ON AN
iPHONE. THAT'S ALL. JUST--
>> YEAH, YEAH, THAT'S THE LAST--
THAT'S THE
END OF IT THE CREDITS GO RIGHT
THERE.
>> Jon: THE WAS THE LAST, THEY
SAID, I THINK WHAT THE YOUNG
BOYS ON THE BUS WENT, "YOU
KNOW WHAT, RACISM IS OVER BUT
LET'S JUST DO THE LAST ONE?
YOU GUYS TO WANT TO BE LAST?"
>> THAT WAS THE LAST
SONG,
THAT WAS THE LAST SONG FOR
RACISM.
>> Jon: THAT WAS THE LAST SONG
FOR RACISM.
>> WE HOPE SO.